well listen i i got some devastating
news that just came in and i hate to
ruin your days
um
anthony fauci said he will not continue
if trump becomes a president
i don't want you guys to be disappointed
by that
uh i know america is probably look we're
probably gonna lose a thousand people
right now getting off immediately
because this is going to be very
disturbing for them but the you know
i don't know if you read what he said
yesterday he said if question was asked
if trump wins will you stay he says no
i'll resign and move on so fortunately
it's
about him not continuing if it's true
i'm sure but i just again i hate to do
this too because i know it bothers you a
lot but i don't want to do that to you
and another number came out yesterday i
don't know if you saw the other number
that came out yesterday because you know
how every time they'll say biden's
approval rating
is the worst we've had except for
donald trump yeah well officially can't
say that anymore because it's the worst
ever measured yeah dude again
two things back to back within a minute
adam uh
approval rating has been the worst in
the last 100 years
uh to the point where you know things
are bad when msnbc
puts stories up saying if this goes the
way the 75
is not happy about the direction that's
going
uh with biden yesterday there was a
question asked of the new press
secretary having to do with the
shortages and inflation because you know
they're trying to blame inflation on
corporate taxes and then jeff bezos i
don't know if you saw the jeff bezos
store if you want to put that up bezos
has never i've i don't think i've ever
seen basil say anything negative
about a
president on the left
and yesterday he just popped off on
twitter
i'm like dude were you having a bad date
that you and your girl get into a big
fight
can you make that a little bit bigger
and click on the jeff bezos tweet not
the other one uh is that the right one
or no is that it
i'll find it
just just type to click on his profile
it'll go to because he doesn't tweet
that often just go up a little bit
you'll see it um
yeah zoom in you'll see it right there
just zoom in
zoom in go up a little bit go up a
little bit go up a little bit the one
right above it i think 200 amazon uh no
that's not it can you find what he says
to
uh uh i think is it the one that says
the best way i think that was it
hey there it is the newly created
disinformation board should review this
tweet by joe biden
or maybe they need to form a new
new non-uh
sequitur board instead raising corporate
taxes is fine to discuss taming
inflation is critical to discuss
mushing them together is just
misdirection by the way this is a man
who hates trump okay this is a man who
him and must go at it all the time you
know they're they're opposing sides and
this is a man who supported this guy and
he's saying this publicly on twitter
look how many likes it's his most liked
tweet of all time okay is that right
we're joe biden on that yeah look at the
click on joe now if you look at bazel's
tweets he doesn't get a lot of likes
look at the like before thirteen
thousand six thousand thirty five
hundred you know two thousand five
thousand and then boom
170 000 people agree with this guy click
on joe biden's tweet by the way click on
joe biden's tweet you want to bring down
inflation let's make sure the wealthiest
corporation pay their fair share
do you realize even if you taxed a
hundred percent of the wealthiest people
it still wouldn't do nothing
if you tax them a hundred percent it
wouldn't do anything
uh with uh where we're at so if you like
this clip and you wanna watch another
one click right here and if you wanna
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]